[Musique]
oui bien des paroles autochtone les
civilisations lundi puis comment on dit
par chez nous ça serait
une raison pourquoi aller d'abord
prendre un peu d'air et répondre à des
questions qui viennent du public
j'adore quand vous m'envoyer des
questions parce que c'est l'occasion que
j'ai de voir aussi quels sont les
besoins qu'est ce que les gens ont comme
répondront accès comme réponse justement
du grand public et la question qu'on
m'envoie semaine staline qui me revient
souvent c'est que je me suis dit oh ça
vaut la peine que j'en repars ou encore
c'est à dire les reconnaissance
territoriale
la question est extrêmement bonne parce
qu'on me dis qu'est ce que vous pensez
des reconnaissances territoriales qui
viennent des organismes d organisation
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
c'est un coup de marketing
très bonne question parce qu'elle a
beaucoup de niveaux premièrement une
reconnaissance territoriale
dépendant d'où elle sort d'où elle vient
d'où elle provient elle a un impact
différent dans le contexte la question
c'est dans un contexte scolaire mais ça
peut aller dans plusieurs autres niveaux
fait que j'ai essayé de démêler un petit
peu ce que j'en pense mais vous pouvez
avoir bien sûr des opinions très
différentes c'est quand même une
question qui est assez chaude au niveau
politique au niveau de la reconnaissance
aussi du droit à l'autodétermination
alors première les premiers niveaux de
reconnaissance territoriale je sors
c'est la reconnaissance individuelle
donc oui moi je m'appelle melissa maulin
10 puis aujourd'hui je reconnais que je
suis un territoire non c'est des
abénakis l'implication que ça là c'est
que j'ai une connaissance d'une
reconnaissance d'ailleurs par rapport au
travail de la nation abénakise sur leur
territoire d'avoir été des protecteurs
vous n'avez pas pendant des milliers
d'années mais ça m'aide aussi à penser à
toutes les autres nations qui passait
sur le territoire faut pas oublier que
dans les dernières décennies avec les
réserves avec la loi sur les indiens
avec aussi la structure coloniale
qui est venu s'imposer aux structures
traditionnelles
une forme de sédentarisation des
territoires qui s'est imposé de lui même
parce qu'il faut pas oublier d'où on
était sur le territoire des nomades ou
des semi nomade donc on se déplace on
laissait des territoires se reposer on
aller ailleurs et tout particulièrement
on n'était pas propriétaire des
territoires vraiment voir la différence
on en était les gardiens devenait
responsable du territoire ont regardé ce
qui s'y passait on prenait soin du
territoire mais toute cette réflexion se
fait aujourd'hui compass en français en
anglais en espagnol se fait avec un
regard euros sans tri de propriétaire ou
gardien c'est toujours une idée de poser
un clin clem c'est moi même une
réclamation sur un territoire et c'est
très difficile d'avoir cette discussion
le cas on
réfléchit d'un point de vue qui est
multiple et culturel donc c'est un peu
comme on parle la même langue on parle
pas la même langue les mots veulent
absolument les même signification mais
moi en tant qu'ils nous en reconnaissant
que je suis en territoire abénakis je
reconnais l'histoire je reconnais leur
place leur importance le rôle de gardien
est donc d'individu à individu je
reconnais justement cette existence donc
c'est important dans un cadre de
réconciliation de pouvoir le faire parce
qu' une des pratiques des citoyens
canadiens c'est de l'ignorer beaucoup la
présence autochtone sur leur propre
territoire de pas connaître les onze
nations par exemple au québec c'était un
enjeu dont je parlais souvent autrefois
et bien aujourd'hui en le reconnaissant
bien on reconnaît qu'on a progressé
aussi dans notre compréhension de
l'existence des communautés autochtones
sur les territoires donc on occupe avec
eux et donc c'est un premier pas en tant
qu'individu que l'on peut faire mais
ensuite la question venait sur les
organismes et les organismes eux ont des
responsabilités très diverses comparé à
l'individu qui le fait à titre personnel
donc le qu'on parle des écoles ça soit
secondaire
cégeps universités qui font de plus en
plus de reconnaissance territoriale bien
il ya une explication par rapport aux
savoirs ancestraux par rapport
à décoloniser les programmes et aussi
par rapport à tirer la clientèle que
l'on veut viser quand on est une
institution d'enseignement qui elle
bénéficie justement d'inscriptions
d'étudiants de recevoir des de l'argent
des bourses ou des financements parce
que une institution éducative elle est
souvent choisi par rapport à ce qu'elle
représente qu'elle offre aux étudiants
donc ça reste quand même un lien
commercial malgré le fait que c'est un
lien d'éducation mais ça laisse quand
même une double implication donc en
faisant cette reconnaissance des
territoires le souvent tu signale que
dans une progression de guérison une
progression de restitution justement des
savoirs de la place des communautés
autochtones dans le curriculum scolaire
donc ça signale quelque chose aux
étudiants autochtones ça signale quelque
chose aux étudiants à l'automne qui eux
ou s'ils veulent voir la réconciliation
progresser donc c'est important oui
c'est une question de marketing
je pense que quand on ne le voit pas
c'est quand on veut on sait qu'il n'y
aura pas de garantie ou quand on sait
que tel service ne sera pas offert que
telle compagnie de vêtements par exemple
9 pas une ligne de vêtements appropriés
à matane oui ça va me faire choisir ou
non un service dont une université un
cégep une colle secondaire qui fait une
reconnaissance des territoires qui
progresse dans sa réconciliation
c'est un très bon coup de marketing pour
eux parce que ça va inviter des gens qui
ont saaq à venir donc pourquoi justice
comme exemple avec moi l'université que
j'ai choisi quand j'étais une étudiante
c'était vraiment en lien avec ce qu'elle
promeut ce qu'elle avait comme promotion
de des droits de l'identité jb tqs la
présence autochtone sur son territoire
et même là quand j'étais à l'intérieur
de l'université avait encore du travail
à faire mais sa poussée dans la
direction que je voulais et non dans le
contraire donc c'est oui c'est une bonne
manière de faire signaler aux gens et
bien ici on fait ce travail là on espère
pouvoir y arriver parce que je pense
qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
rattraper dans les niveaux scolaires
mais c'est une progression qui se fait
et qui est déviée par la clientèle qui
va utiliser ses institutions la leur on
rentre avec aussi le niveau marketing
mais des
des compagnies de ce qu'ils nous vendent
un produit là on rentre dans quelque
chose d'autre c'est pas un savoir
universel qui vendu c'est un produit
donc là toute une haute responsabilité
si on reconnaît un territoire si on
reconnaît une nation si on reconnaît
qu'on emprunte quelque chose de culturel
au territoire qu'on exploite par exemple
si on va aller fabriquer un produit prêt
à partir dans nos produits terroir qu'on
utilise seulement l'image ou identité
autochtone pour le vent mais est ce
qu'il ya une relation est ce qu'il ya
une compréhension et en faisant une
reconnaissance de territoire en créant
une relation avec les membres des
communautés qui sont présents puissent
faire le marketing mais c'est un
marketing social qui est différent
peut-être de ce qu'on a vu par le passé
donc c'est très nouveau il ré dernier
niveau que moi j'aime identifié quatre
grands niveau là c'est gouvernementale
et c'est là où est ce que des fois c'est
plus sensibles quand un membre du
gouvernement comme une institution
gouvernementale reconnais un territoire
parce qu'elle est
un peu un peu plus officiel de plus
politique avec les communautés
autochtones donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
vue dernièrement justement nouveau
brunswick au québec les reconnaissances
territoriales et les membres du
gouvernement sont un peu plus frileux à
les offrir parce que ça fait de vue
comme des attestations de reconnaissance
de droit et j'ai ces droits là sont
souvent contestées par ces mêmes
gouvernements là donc c'est toujours
très très très sensible et c'est une
discussion qui est encore très cher donc
oui chaque personne chaque individu
chaque institution qui fait une
reconnaissance de territoire le fait
pour une raison x y z il ya une côte et
de marketing c'est une manière
d'afficher ou de promouvoir une
réflexion et ça veut souvent dire qu'il
ya un engagement dans cette direction
donc en quelqu'un qui fait une
reconnaissance de territoire qui fait
une reconnaissance et répond sans trop
comprendre kerry qui fait pas une
reconnaissance de territoire vous pouvez
comprendre qu'il ya des approches qui
vont nous permettre de choisir peut-être
de façon plus sécuritaire pour les
communautés autochtones des services des
universités des écoles mais il ya
toujours du travail à faire et ça c'est
normal si c'est long une réconciliation
on ne fait pas cent cinquante ans de
colonisation en seulement dix ans et
c'est quand même une meilleure
progression qu'est ce qu'on voyait
autrefois quand ils ne pouvaient même
pas nommé les nations sur lesquels leurs
universités l'heure si on se trouve donc
merci beaucoup pour ta question parce
que c'est une question qui à plusieurs
niveaux qui va se passer sur plusieurs
paliers et que des gens vont être
d'accord ou pas d'accord certaines
personnes ne veulent absolument pas pour
phase de reconnaissance de territoire
parce que il considère qu'on a perdu une
guerre qui n'est pas vrai il considère
qu on reconnaît des membres canadiens
dessous et canadiens que les mêmes
droits mêmes canadiens ont pas tête à
marc gascon et les premières nations des
popotes octobre et on a des droits qui
sont distincts des autres canadiens on a
des territoires aussi qu'ils sont des
territoires de réserve et aussi des
territoires traditionnels dont la
politique canadienne les droits
autochtones commence à peine à être
découvert par le grand public et
l'implication dé reconnaissance
territoriale selon qui la fait aussi at
il dit je pense qu'on perd jamais rien à
reconnaître qu'on est sur un téléphone
parce qu'on fait au moins reconnaissance
de la nation avec qui on partage de
territoire et ça c'est très important de
2,1 visibiliser les communautés alors
juste une semaine n'hésitez pas à nous
envoyer des questions parce qu'on adore
les recevoir et c'était pas non plus à
partager cette vidéo on est disponible
sur beaucoup de plateformes et on va
essayer de garder le moral tout ça